vidit is a pawn up in what appears to me  to be a winning rook ending at first  sight but i may have misjudged this but  uh the tara shrook the rook supporting  the passport from behind  according to  the german  master  uh is the key to victory in these rook  endings and i think that uh  this time around i got this right that  this end game is all over  um generally what tends to happen is is  that it fizzles into a pawn ending like  c7 king d6 king up and whilst black is  trying to eliminate the passer on that  side white warps up the rest  okay well that's significant because  you know where he  loses a second game so he falls behind  now  you know he did start the day  right at the top so it's not he's not in  danger yet but he'll be disappointed  with that one of course